-This dress-code thing
may seem like whatever to you,
it may seem like whatever
to all of you,
but I'd say it's another way
to control women.
And if you're doing nothing,
then you're part of the problem.
So where do you stand
with these tank tops, huh?
-Where am I gonna stand?
I obviously am going to stan
on the side of equality
and freedom for all and --
and diversity, and --
and to come together as --
as both sides,
the -- the --
the male and the female,
the alpha and the omega,
guy and gal.
I have to go
to the bathroom so bad.
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We are here with Ike Barinholtz,
who is fantastic as a teache
in the great new film "Moxie."
And, Ike, I know you're an
"education first" kind of guy.
-Yes.
-From being your friend,
I know you graduated from your
freshman year of college.
[ Laughter ]
-I did it all in one year.
I got the full experience,
and Boston University said
"We're good.
You're good.
Don't come back, no matter what.
But God bless you."
And then, I went into improv
-It's one of my
favorite stories, but you di
have to let your parents know.
You kept it from them
for a while
about exactly
what had happened at college
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I knew things weren't goin
in the right direction,
and I was too scared
to be honest with them
'cause I'm a coward.
And so I didn't tell them
anything.
And they were so proud
that I finished my first yea
of college that my dad,
who you know -- great guy --
-Alan, number one.
-Alan, number one,
took me on a trip to --
took me to Las Vegas,
Los Angeles,
and we had a great time.
And then on the way home,
they found out
that I had been kicked out
And, you know, when you're
sitting on a Southwest fligh
with your old man,
and he's about to cry, it sucks.
It sucks to be in seat 11C
[ Laughter ]
-You know,
I think you should look --
'Cause, you know, I finished
my freshman year, and I got --
-Oh, good for you!
Congratulations!
[ Laughter ]
-Well, my point was that,
you know, Larry,
who you know well --
-Yes.
-Like, he wasn't like,
"You finished the year.
We're going to Vegas!"
And, you know,
maybe that's why --
You know, maybe, like,
some seeds were planted
early on by Alan
that, you know, he should shar
the responsibility, that's all
-Yeah, in hindsight,
it would have been great
if they waited
until I finished all four years.
But then I would never
have been on this path,
and my dad would have
never have met Kevin Nealon.
[ Laughter ]
So everyone wins.
-Hey, you are -- you have thre
beautiful daughters,
and all jokes aside,
this is a really empowering film
for young women.
Can you talk to us a little bi
about the premise?
-Yeah, so it is about
this high school,
and there's some
toxic masculinity
that's kind of in the DNA
of this high school.
And this is a story about
a group of young women
who kind of realize they don't
have to put up with it.
And, uh,
they do something about it
And they kind of --
the main character is kind o
inspired by her mom,
played by Poehler.
And she kind of starts
this punk-rock 'zine
and kind of starts
this little revolution
at, uh, at the school.
And my teacher -- my character
is just this hot teacher
kind of caught
in the middle of it all.
[ Laughter ]
He doesn't know what to do
He's just weighing
whether or not
he should continue in educatio
or go back to modeling.
-Yeah. That seems to be, like,
not quite a B story.
I feel like it's a J story
-Amy assured me
it was a D story.
And she says, "If Netflix
likes it, it's in."
And so I haven't seen
the second half of the movie
Last night, I watched
the first half with the kids
and we're gonna watch
the second half.
I think it's in there.
I hope it's in there.
I hope it's in there!
We'll figure it out.
-It's a great young cast.
There's a Schwarzenegger
in the film --
Patrick Schwarzenegger.
-There is.
-I know you have
a Schwarzenegger impression.
Were you able to resist doing it
in front of his kin?
-Yes.
Patrick Schwarzenegger
is Arnold's son.
He's a wonderful kid,
great actor.
But I -- for many years,
my generation just --
our default was either
Christopher Walken
or Arnold Schwarzenegger.
So, like, every time I saw him
I had to make sure I didn'
quote "Pumping Iron."
You know what I mean?
Like, "Hey, good morning.
Don't drink milk.
Drink beer.
Milk is for babies."
Like, I had to not do that
And it hurt, it hurt.
But I made it through.
-Thanks for giving us a taste.
And thank you so much
for being here.
Ike, it is a pleasure.
I am so looking forward
to being near you again.
I love you very much, buddy.
-Love you, buddy.
Bye, guys.
-"Moxie" is streaming
on Netflix now.